- For 20 years my
camera's led me
to some pretty
extraordinary places.
I could have never imagined
that I would be standing
on the streets of a place
like Pyongyang, North Korea
and 20 years later I came
back to the United States
with my cameras and it's been
every bit as mind blowing.
(applause)
NatGeo spent a year
covering Yellowstone.
They had a single topic
issue this summer.
There were many
decorated National
Geographic photographers
out there but the rest of
them were inside the park
showing the landscapes,
the wild life,
the biology,
the tourists, the glory
of our public land.
My job was to stand
outside the boundaries
of Yellowstone National
Park because NatGeo knew
it was just as important
to tell the story
of the people who live on
the other side of the line
and what it means to live
adjacent to a national park.
On my first day I drove through
Yellowstone National Park
this is what I saw.
Welcome back to
America, ground zero.
So I lived my life
outside of the boundaries
of the park.
Little towns like Livingston,
I photographed them
in the same way that
I photographed my life
in North Korea
and anywhere else.
In the bars where I ate
dinner, on main streets.
I started my own new
Instagram series,
I called this one Work Commute.
Work Commute wasn't only
to make all of the editors
jealous that they were
sitting in an office all day
and this is where I was working.
It was also that idea
that we could take people
out into the field.
That a National Geographic story
lasts for an entire year
so why not bring
people along with you.
I had another series
#dogsinpickuptrucks.
(laughter)
but what National Geographic
really wanted me to do
in Yellowstone was tackle issues
and mainly they wanted me
to look at the conflict
and confluence between
people and wildlife.
The first thing that
I covered were bison.
Bison have had a very dark
history in our country.
We once had 50 maybe
60 million of them
roaming North America.
We killed them down
to just a handful
but it was also the moment
when human beings
looked after animals
and the conservation
movement was born
and they brought them
back from extinction
and now the core DNA...
American Bison
that we have today
live inside Pelican Valley
in Yellowstone National Park
but they only have room for
four, maybe 5000 of them
and every year they come
out and cross the line
and wander into our yards
and into our highways.
The bison was named our
national mammal this year
and yet in the
west in many places
it's still registered
as livestock.
Can you imagine the
bald eagle as livestock,
kept in a chicken coop?
They're not that loved
actually by a lot of people
in the west because of...
The proximity that
they live to the parks.
Who couldn't love this guy?
He was being- this is a
Yellowstone bison,
he was being tagged and tested
for a disease
called Brucellosis.
Many people don't love bison
because they fear this disease
and that they will transfer
this disease to their cattle
once they cross
outside of Yellowstone
and this bison tested positive
and this is how they dealt
with it.
Very quickly, execution style.
So they're looking
for solutions,
how to manage bison,
how to deal with them
how to protect them
but also live with them.
And one of the solutions is
Native American hunting rights
as the bison cross
over into our land
outside of public land,
they give a certain number
of hunting licenses
to the native peoples.
I had the privilege of
going with these men
and watching them as
they hunted this bison
and ceremoniously removing
its heart in a field
and they've started
a new program too
where they instead of killing
them they round them up
put them in these
trucks and ship them off
to the Native
America Reservations
because native peoples
have a direct connection
to the bison.
When this truck arrived in
Fort Belknap in the north
of Montana they let out school,
all the kids came,
all the elders came
and people celebrated
as they let them go
and let them lose
on their land again.
I photographed elk.
It's probably the animal
that's maybe the pulse
of Yellowstone.
It's what the bears
and the wolves eat.
It's also what brings in
millions of tourists every year.
These beautiful animals
that you can see them
practically no other place.
But again outside of the line
people see them a
very different way.
There's almost a cult of hunting
and it's big business too.
So I tried to go
right on the line
that separates the park
from the rest of the state.
This line right
behind the hunter,
that's the actual boundary
of Yellowstone National Park
and the hunters come here, put
themselves right on the line
and wait for elk to
come up over the hill.
The elk know where that
line is, it's amazing.
When they cross it's
like they just saunter in
home free but when they don't
like this one on the right,
the hunter shot him, he
stood up, he struggled,
trying to get to the line
and he shot him again,
he slid right to the
line and the hunter said,
"It's a good thing he didn't
make it to the other side
"cause we wouldn't have been
able to retrieve him legally."
This is not a hunter, this
is a biologist darting a wolf
for research purposes.
Wolves were reintroduced
into Yellowstone
in the mid-1990s because
they didn't believe
that the ecosystem
could be healthy
without an alpha
predator like the wolf
and they're loved
inside the park.
Tourists name them, they
watch them with remote cameras
from laptops in their homes,
they have tattoos on
their arms of wolves
and when they see them
through a spotting scope
they break down in tears.
It's quite amazing but
again outside of the park
it's a different story.
Ranchers fear them because
they come onto their property,
they eat their livestock
and actually they just see
them in many ways as demons,
the big bad wolf.
And these are not people
who are used to doing things
any other way than settling
them in their own way.
They told me, "we're used
to living with wolves now
and we know that
they're here to stay
but we don't like the
federal government telling us
what to do."
But they're learning to
live with wolves and bears
and they're learning to ranch
and to live their
lives differently.
They used to just
send these sheep up
into national forest
land and let them graze
for the season all alone
but now they go with them, they
sleep every night out there
with the sheep and
I did this too.
I followed them all
the way to the top
of the Gravelly Mountains.
The animal that's on most
peoples minds right now
are grizzly bears.
Grizzlies have been protected
as an endangered species
for something like 40 years
and maybe as a sign
of their recovery
the numbers are greater,
they're coming further down
into lower lands, they're
becoming a bit more habituated.
Now we find them in the
front lawns eating apples
out of our apple trees.
This is Dusty,
he's a bear trapper
for the state of Montana.
He's sort of like a dog catcher
or like a beat cop.
He goes around,
he educates people
how to protect their garbage
and how to protect bears
by not allowing them
to become habituated
but he also gets his 911 calls,
"Hey there's a bear
on my roof again."
and they go and they dart
them and they bring them back
to the garage and they sometimes
euthanize them if the
bear becomes too difficult
to deal with
but usually like this
bear, they tag their ear,
they brush their teeth,
they give them inoculations
and then they drive them from
Wyoming to the Montana border
and they let them go
on the other side.
And the bear catchers in
Montana told me the same thing.
They bring them into
Wyoming, open the door,
let em go into Wyoming.
This man's name is Nick Patrick.
He knows better than
anyone what it means
to live on that line,
to live with the wild,
to live with bears.
He's a rancher from Wyoming.
One day he was walking in
his yard with his dogs,
his dogs start barking
and they ran off
into the willow trees.
He thought maybe they
were chasing a raccoon
so he walked in behind them,
he didn't have his bear spray
and he found himself
suddenly caught
between a huge sow grizzly
bear and her two cubs.
Before he could do anything,
the grizzly was on him.
He said with one swipe it
took off his entire face.
He fell to the ground, it
mauled him, he played dead,
she let him go.
As she was walking away
he reached into his pocket
to see if he had something
to protect himself,
she turned and saw him.
She was on him again,
she mauled him,
dragged him by his leg.
She let him live.
He walked back from the
willow trees into his barn
and he found a shop rag
and he covered his face
so that he could go
and tell his wife
and his children that
he'd been injured.
He didn't want them to see
what had happened to him.
And he walked in the
house and told them to,
"Take me to the hospital."
When we first
started this project
we wanted to photograph Nick
because Nick tells that story
of living with wild
better than anyone else
but he said he didn't want
to be photographed then
because he hadn't had the
reconstructive surgery
that you see in this picture.
He hadn't been given this
new prosthetic silicone nose
and he said, "I don't want to
be photographed like this yet"
and it wasn't
because Nick is vain,
it's because Nick said,
"I don't want my face
to tell the wrong story
and scare people away."
because Nick believes that
we have to live with the wild
and Nick says that, "That
mother was doing what any mother
"would do, protect
her children."
and Nick said, "I want my face
to tell a different story,
"I want it to tell a story
"of how we should
protect the land
"and we should
protect the wild life
"and that we have to
learn to live among them."
So National Geographic
spent this entire year 2016
photographing national parks.
This was the centennial of the
creation of the park service.
Every issue had a story
about a national park
and I tried to go to
as many as I could too
now that I was back in America.
I took my children, we
went to the Badlands,
we went to the Everglades
and I hung around
with these invasive
python hunters
and I went to Yosemite.
I got to go with President
Obama to Yosemite National Park.
He was there on fathers'
day to tour the park
with his family but also
to announce even more land
and seas that he and our
government decided to protect.
With that announcement
he solidified his legacy
as the best president
that we've ever had
for conservation, protecting
more land and seas
than any other before him.
I got the chance to walk
through the forest with him.
Just me and a
couple of cameramen
and at the end he
shook our hands
and I thanked him and he said,
"Hey, aren't you the guy
who took all those pictures
in North Korea?"
(laughter)
I said "Yes," and I said
"What did you think?"
and he said, "It's good,
I think it was important
"we got to see something
we don't normally see."
and he started to walk
away and he turned around
and he said, "Hey, just
be careful over there,
"I don't want to have
to come over there
"and rescue you and
bring you back home."
(laughter)
but I made it home,
exactly 20 years
from the time that I left.
It was actually 4th
of July the first day
that I came back.
I went to my sister's house,
she had a 4th of July party.
Now that I'm home, I
guess I kind of often
feel like a stranger
in a strange land
after being away for so long
and so I notice and I
photograph the things
that maybe outsiders
would notice.
All the patriotism and the flags
and the sugary diet that we have
and maybe I'm a little critical
but I also know that
my sister made these
and so I also feel love
and I also feel like
I'm happy to be home again.
This is my front yard
where I moved back to.
This is the frozen lake outside
of the house I'm living in.
Those are my footsteps
going out onto the lake
and back to my yard.
I had to go quite far
out into the world
for a long time
to feel like I could answer
that voice in my head and
that I could find my purpose
and that I could bring
that purpose back intact
and that I could notice all
the little bits of beauty
right here in my own country
and in my own back yard.
And so maybe for most
of you, you didn't have
to quite go so far.
You knew that from the beginning
but for me I had
to go a long way
before I could come back home.
So I want to end by just
thanking National Geographic
because they
brought me back home
and they're still
sending me out there
into the wild so
thank you very much.
(applause)